you'll know we've done this enough times
that when you're learning something new
you want to connect it as much as you
can to your previous knowledge because
they're number one you'll understand the
new stuff better because you're like oh
this is just like the thing they used to
do with this and also it's really
important for us to emphasize to you the
mathematics syllabus the curriculum that
we learned it's not just a bunch of
disconnected bits right it's like a
story chapter one lays the chapter 2 2
to 3 3 to 4 everything's interconnected
so I want you to think to some of the
graphing that we've been doing over the
past few weeks and we'll start with some
familiar shapes well you all know we've
actually known for a good couple of
years now what y equals x squared what
it looks like firstly what's the name of
this shape it's a parabola right and
what can you tell me about this
particular parabola just y equals x
squared yeah it's on now that's again I
know you took yeah keep going okay
fantastic let me just repeat that in
case you can catch it it's facing up we
say it's concave up like a smiley face
right and it's got the y axis here as
the axis of surgery so it's kinda like
right down the middle right and we could
add to that as well because if Sean did
tell us where it was
sort of you know is it to the left is it
to the right no it's right smack bang in
the middle and it also has an important
feature the vertex where is that for y
equals x squared the vertex is at the
origin that's actually really important
I'd love us to highlight that there the
vertex is at 0 0 right now that becomes
very important to note when we think
about well see this guy here Y minus K
equals X minus H squared that's also
going to give you a parabola it's
basically the same kind of algebraic
setup but that K and that H they just
take this shape and they subtly change
it what kind of way does do this K and H
how do they change this parabola
does it change whether it's facing up or
down
it's either yes or no which one is it
in this case no how would I change this
what would I do if I want a difference
down yeah I'm gonna like stuff a minus
side here or here okay so that that has
not happened so it's still going to be
facing up but the vertex is no longer
going to be a zero zero is it okay where
would the vertex be in this case C let's
think horizontally first right I'm going
to move H units somewhere to the left of
the right very good so this is that
reverse thing right negatives are this
side of the axis but when you have X
minus H you're gonna move the whole
shape viewed H units to the right what
about that K what's that going to do K
units upward right you could have
written for example I could have written
y equals this plus K yeah oh yeah that's
that's upwards right so we can draw a
new parabola here because I've let K and
H be anything we can literally put it
anywhere but the important thing is it
will be in every regard identical so
this parabola but its vertex will be
somewhere else in this case there's the
x-coordinate goes with the X there's the
y-coordinate goes with the Y so I'm
going to label that vertex that's H
comma okay
all right so this was our friend the
parabola but then more recently we've
been looking a little more carefully at
this guy this is not a parabola these
two what do we call this shape it ends
in the same way but don't start the same
way it's a it's a hyperbola very good so
the hyperbola parabola hyperbola by the
way not a coincidence that their names
are very similar a hyperbola is this
weird guy here it's got these two
branches Jeremy that there's like this
will you the part over here yeah and
then it's got its counterpart over here
now now that we've got sort of both
categories a graph on the board might as
well mention both graphs have a kind of
symmetry what kind of symmetry does the
parabola have what's its called it's got
a name right it does have an axis of
symmetry but it has the function is a
particular client of sintering what's it
called
ah now odd symmetry and even symmetry
right are the two kinds but which one is
which I'll give you a clue
this is x squared this is even symmetry
if it was an X cubed and have odd
symmetry if R is X to the 4
can you guess what kind of symmetry
would have even right so it comes with
that number this is even symmetry I
might even write that down just to
remind myself even symmetry and down
here is this even this is not even it's
odd isn't it yeah so it's kind of cool
you know I got a negative that's X to
the power of negative 1 is cut like an
odd number right but more importantly
like if you took this shape if you took
your book which I can't do to the white
board and you rotated it around you'd
get the same shape wouldn't you if you
were ten hundred eighty okay is this
graph complete is there any other
important stuff I should probably put on
there yes what am I missing yep
asymptotes that's fine that's okay how
many asymptotes am I thinking of there
will be two for this right
where am I going to put can someone tell
me where one of them will go okay
straight you're doing something with
your arms he used some words as well
okay there's gonna be one on the x-axis
very good there you go so it's equation
is y equals zero and rest in your joint
tell me where the other one is it's also
it's also the y-axis very good okay so
you've got your horizontal asymptote
you've got your vertical asymptote worth
reminding you that the vertical
asymptotes like you can never ever cross
the vertical asymptote right because if
I put in x equals zero what happens to
this equation when I put in X equal zero
yeah it becomes undefined it just
explodes in your face you're like great
I can't do that right but this y equals
zero one in this case we don't cross it
but actually we're totally allowed to
this horizontal asymptote can you see
the graph just kind of ignores it in the
middle right the graph is not
approaching there in the middle it's
only approaching at the edges we call
these the extremities okay so you've got
two different very very different kinds
of asymptotes right where do the
asymptotes me
whether they meet they meet at zero zero
at the origin right right there smoke
there okay now this is important because
I now want to think about this sky and
you know how you told me are when you
take this regular parabola you then move
it right it's not just the vertex that
moves the whole thing moves okay this
you can see we've got the set up the
same now we looked at this right where's
the vertical asymptote on this going to
be have a look where's that what value
of x are you not allowed to put into
this it just explodes so we don't want
the holder we don't want the denominator
to be 0 but what value of x would make
that denominator 0 H X is not allowed to
equal H so in the same way that x equals
0 is an asymptote here x equals H will
be an asymptote here let me put that in
our matters I'll do it sort of
vertically in line like that
ok so this is the vertical line x equals
H now not only am i moving like left and
right I'm also moving up and down how
many units am i moving up and down I'm
gonna move K units up or down up just
like here right like it's the same deal
it's the same idea so you know how you
had this horizontal asymptote
it was just there at y equals 0 I'm not
gonna be awake Wazir anymore I'm you
just taught me to move up K units so it
won't be awake was your it'll be y
equals K so I'm gonna move that guy up
like so ok so I might even label that y
equals ok so you know over here how we
got the asymptotes meeting at the origin
right where do our asymptotes meet for
this guy let's just look familiar
it's at this same point that we
identified vote right yeah HK if I got
that yeah H goes with the X and K goes
with the why is that ok so that's that
point there H comma K and then you can
sort of draw the rest of the hyperbola
just like you did before it might look
something like this if you knew what H
and K were you could then subsequently
use that to find the intercepts and you
definitely need that like you see how I
intersect with the axis you want to find
this point